i've been working in ai for most of my
career helping companies build
artificial intelligence capabilities to
improve their business
which is why i think what i'm about to
tell you is quite shocking
every year
thousands of companies across the world
spend collectively tens of billions of
dollars to build ai capabilities
but according to research my colleagues
and i have done only about 10 percent of
these companies get any meaningful
financial impact from their investments
these 10 winners with ai have a secret
and their secret is not about fancy
algorithms or sophisticated technology
it's something far more basic
it's how they get their people and ai to
work together together not against each
other not instead of each other together
in a mutually beneficial relationship
unfortunately when most people think
about ai they think about the most
extreme cases
that ai is here only to replace us or
overtake our intelligence and make us
unnecessary but what i'm saying is that
we don't seem to quite appreciate the
huge opportunity that exists in the
middle ground
where humans and ai come together
to achieve outcomes that neither one
could do alone on their own
consider the game of chess you probably
knew that ai today can beat any human
grandmaster
but did you know that the combination of
a human chess player and ai can beat not
only any human but also any machine the
combination is much more powerful than
the sum of its parts
in a perfect combination ai will do what
it does best which is dealing with
massive amounts of data and solving
complex problems and humans do what we
do best
using our creativity our judgment our
empathy our ethics and our ability to
compromise
for several years my colleagues and i
have studied and worked with hundreds of
winning companies who are successfully
building these human ai relationships
and what we've seen is quite interesting
first of all these companies get five
times more financial value than
companies who use ai only to replace
people
most importantly they have a happier
workforce their employees are more proud
more fulfilled they collaborate better
with each other and they're more
effective
five times more value and a happier
workforce so the question is how do
these companies do it how do they
achieve these symbiotic human ai
relationships
i have some answers
first of all they don't think of ai in
the most extreme case only to replace
humans instead they look deep inside
their organizations and at the various
roles their people play and they ask how
can ai make our people more fulfilled
more effective more amplified let me
give you an example
humana is a healthcare company here in
the us
it has pharmacy call centers where
pharmacists work with patients over the
phone
it's a job that requires a fair amount
of empathy and humanity
humana has developed an ai system that
listens to the pharmacist conversation
and picks up emotional and tone signals
and then gives real-time suggestions to
the pharmacist on how to improve the
quality of that conversation
for example it might say slow down or
pause or hey consider how the other
person is feeling right now all to
improve the quality of that conversation
i'm pretty sure my wife would buy me one
of these if she could uh just to help me
in some of my conversations with her
turns out the pharmacists like it quite
a lot too
they're more effective in their jobs but
they also learn something about
themselves their own behaviors and
biases
result has been more effective
pharmacists and much higher customer
satisfaction scores now this is just one
example of many possibilities where
human ai collaborates in this example ai
was a recommender it didn't replace the
human or make any decisions of its own
it simply made suggestions and it was up
to the person to decide and act
and at the heart of it is a feedback
loop which by the way is very critical
for any human ai relationship
by that i mean that in this example
first
i had to learn from humans the qualities
that would make up a good or not so good
conversation
and then over time as ai builds more
intelligence it would be able to make
suggestions
but it would be up to the person
to decide and act
and if they didn't agree with the
recommendation because it might have not
made sense to them they didn't have to
in which case ai might learn something
and adapt for the future
it's basically open frequent two-way
communication like any couples therapist
will tell you is very important for any
good relationship
now the key word here is relationship
think about your own personal
relationships with other people you
don't have the same kind of relationship
with your accountant or your boss or
your spouse do you
well i certainly hope not and just like
that the right relationship between
human and ai in a company is not a
one-size-fits-all
so in the case of humana ai was a
recommender and human was decision maker
and actor
in some other examples ai might be an
evaluator
where human comes up with ideas or
scenarios and ai evaluates the complex
implications and trade-offs of those
ideas and makes it easy for humans to
decide the best course of action
in some other examples i might take a
more creative role it could be an
illuminator where it can take a complex
problem and come up with potential
solutions to that problem and illuminate
some options that might have been
impossible for humans to see
let me give you another example
during the covet pandemic if you walked
into a retail or grocery store you saw
that many retailers were struggling
their shelves were empty their suppliers
were not able to fulfill the orders and
with all the uncertainties of the
pandemic they simply had no idea how
many people would be walking into what
stores demanding what products
now to put this in perspective this is a
problem that's already quite hard when
things are normal retailers have to
predict demand for tens of thousands of
products across thousands of locations
and thousands of suppliers every day
to manage and optimize their inventory
add to that the uncertainties of covid
and the global supply chain disruptions
and this became a hundred times more
difficult and many retailers were simply
paralyzed
but there were a few
who had built strong foundations with ai
and the human ai feedback loop that we
talked about and these guys were able to
navigate all this uncertainty much
better than others
they used ai to analyze tens of billions
of data points on consumer behavior and
global supply chain disruptions and
local government closures and mandates
and
traffic on highways and ocean freight
lanes and many many other factors and
get a pretty good handle on what
consumers in each unique area
wanted the most
what would have been feasible and for
items that were not available what
substitutions could be made
but ai alone without the human touch
wouldn't work either there were ethical
and economic tradeoffs that had to be
considered for example deciding to bring
in a product that didn't have a good
margin for the retailer but would really
help support the local community at
their time of need
after all a i couldn't quite understand
the uniquely human behavior of panic
buying toilet vapor or tens of gallons
of liquor only to be used as hand
sanitizer
it was the combination that was the key
and the winning companies know this
they also know that inside their
companies there's literally hundreds of
these opportunities for human ai
combination and they actively identify
and pursue them
they think of ai as much more broadly a
means to replace people
they look inside their organizations and
reimagine how the biggest challenges and
opportunities of their company can be
addressed by the combination of human
and ai
and they put in place the right
combination for each unique situation
whether it's the recommender or the
evaluator or the illuminator or
optimizer or many many other ones they
build and evolve the feedback loops that
we talked about and finally and most
importantly they don't just throw
technology at it
in fact this has been the biggest
pitfall of companies who don't get their
return from their ai investments if they
over invest in technology expecting a
piece of tech to solve all their
problems
but there is no silver bullet technology
and automation can only go so far and
for every one automation opportunity
inside a company there's literally 10
for collaboration
but collaboration's hard it requires a
new mindset and doing things differently
than how we've always done it
and the winning companies know this too
which is why they don't just invest in
technology but so much more on human
factors on their people on training and
reskilling and reimagining how their
people and ai work together in new ways
inside these companies it's not just
machines replacing humans
it's machines and humans working
together learning from each other
and when that happens the organization's
overall rate of learning increases which
in turn makes the company much more
agile much more resilient ready to adapt
and take on any challenge
it is the human touch that will bring
the best out of ai
thank you
[Applause]